الاشياء المنتظره الكبيره وهي المساعدات
الانسانيه القادمه من الدول المانحه او
المنظمات الامميه الكبيره كان الامم
المتحده جامده خاصه في تركيا وهي معنتها
الامم المتحده قال ان لديها شحنات كبيره
من المواد الاغاثيه والطبيه عالقه في
تركيا يفهم بان الطرقات متقطعه ومتضرره
وبالتالي لا تستطيع الامم المتحده ادخال
هذه الشحنات عبر معبر باب الهوى الى مناطق
المعارضه اي الى شمال الغربي من سوريا وهي
المناطق الاكثر تضررا في سوريا من هذا
الزلزال والاقل من ناحيه الموارد سواء
الموارد الطبيه او البشريه او حتى يعني
الاليات الثقيله المطلوبه لرفع الانقراض
يعني جهود الاغاثيه جهود رفع الانقاض في
مستوياتها الدنيا وهو ما يعني
يفسر بارتفاع اعداد الضحايا نحن كنا نتحدث
قبل ساعتين عن 1612 اصبح العدد 712 والان
نحن نتحدث لربما عن ارقام تقترب من
الالفين شخص قتلوا جراء هذا الزلزال في
عموما المتزايده جمعه يتم اخراجها من تحت
الانقاض
نعم يعني عدد كبير من الجرحى الذين تم
انشائها العمليات المعقده لهم داخل
المشافي فرقوا الحياه يعني في مشفى عفرين
العسكري لوحده شهده 83 حاله وفاه كانوا
هؤلاء قد وصلوا كجرحى يعني كمصابين من تحت
الارقام وصلوا الى هذا المستشفى يعني كان
هناك ثلاثه جثث فقط في مشفى واحد في مدينه
يعني جنديرس بسبب يعني عدم قدره طواقم
الدفاع وطواقم الانقاذ رفع الانقاض هناك
حديث عن وجود حوالي 150 شخص فارقوا الحياه
في هذه البلده الصغيره 84 مبنى مدمر